all those magazines together and seems oh there's
hardly a family in my neighborhood that ain't
taking one or more alert so I got to thinking
about the Texaco ads and all them magazines the
Texaco billboards the Texaco radio programs and
I got to thinking what this advertising all means
to me to me personally so I got to studying and
I got to thinking of Texaco advertising kind of
a different feeling I mean some mighty heart
forming discoveries take the magazine ads and
take the billboards well the more I studied them
the more it come to me that well fellers said
did you ever notice how one guy can tell a story
and hardly nobody will even crack a smile or pay
much attention to him now another guy before he's
hardly got started that they've got him sitting
up and chuckling hanging on to every word that
he says and it's the same way with advertising
some ads get folks to reading them and agreeing
with them and some don't I'd like to show you
some of the ads that Texaco is going to run for us
this year let's see for yourself if I ain't right
when I say that Texaco has got a real knack for
attracting attention and telling the story oh all
right okay operator do you mind Fleiss not a few
of those ads for us Oh smoke means trouble that
ain't a swell picture of a real boy in trouble
I don't know what is that's bound to make every
man who sees it to call the time he tried out
one of his dad cigars a little too soon for the
sole missed that one smoke means trouble boys it
sure does when it comes from excess where in your
motor this and tells folks that whenever they see
a car on the road was smoked for now exhaust pipe
you can bet it's probably cause the wire we're
that the right oil might have prevented course
once she smokes like a chimney what's this darn
232 smoking chimney I was just starting to say
that once the car starts smoking like that ain't
nothing can be done except an expensive repair job
and darned is there anything that about a smoking
chimney then here's a picture that'll make folks
stop breathe the same way smoking shirts are
smoking cars they both mean the same thing
trouble every time anybody sees a smoking car in
the road they just can't help remember these ads
and before the cars start to smoke and lose power
from too much wear of be plenty more of them come
in by Avila we've got some bang-up airs on Texaco
motor oil again this year short easy to read to
the point and every ad tell us about the price
how cheap it is and how many miles you get but
see for yourself I don't have to tell you how good
they are and now I'd like to tell you something
about the registered restroom campaign remember
last year we had a swell ad and a bill poster
showing the same little girl well they tell me the
advertising people had so many nice comments on
that advertisement that they decide to run another
one next you lies there like it is possible with a
little different twist to the headline so here's
the little girl back again only this year she's
a tourist the advertiser people sure know a good
thing when they got it and they got it all right
when they got the idea such a little tyke being
a tourist there's another registered restroom
ad that's gonna run in the magazines right after
that one I'd like to show you that one too but it
ain't ready yet and speaking of knowing a good
thing when they've got it the Texas company is
going to keep going in 1941 on that piece of mind
theme this done is so much good Donmar fact we're
gonna keep reminding folks how they keep worrying
about what their dogs gonna do next how it gives
them the jitters when fati sits in the antique
chair of the wife's are proud of and all funny
things like that and how us Texaco dealers can
take one worry off their mind and that's proper
chassis lubrication with Martha yes sir once it
takes a coal folks hit on something that does
you and me a lot of good they got sense enough to
stick to it same way remember last year we started
night service across the country companies gonna
keep it up again this year I just like to show
you one of the ads that's going to be run on
all night service if that is something that's
going to make people think the Texaco dealers
are doing everything to help people on their
way at night then I give up and I know it'll give
you and me a mighty lot of good and making people
feel more friendly and grateful for the kind of
thoughtful service we give now while we're at
it here's some more Texaco advertisement the 1941
series on sky teeth remember we had ads last year
showing drawings for this cartoonist it seems
to me he's better than ever and they said where
they're proven the sky chief starts quicker than
a jackrabbit and in this one to where he's got
some inventor with a nutty contraction to start
card the headline says somebody ought to tell
him about sky chief gasoline and to quit fooling
around with such gadgets now these sky chief and
seem to me to be just what I was telling you and
make for tell the story so it gets over to fault
same with fire chief advertisement snappy get
up in color so it's to catch the eye and mighty
little copy so if folks can get our message quick
there's going to be six to four ads altogether and
the advertising folks tell me that they spread out
these ads and the magazine's so that we really get
an ad coming out on fire chief for dinner every
week fact is they tried to explain to me how all
these Texaco advertising can things are spread
through all the leading popular magazines all
year so it's kind of a neighborhood spider web
they're knitting from the cat nobody nowhere is
the state problem sorta made my head swim to hear
them tell how it's done scientific life but that
didn't prevent me from feeling kind good all over
about it yep even the leading business magazines
have got Texaco campaigns running them so as to
sell businessman and executives on Texaco and
all the main farm magazines to with ads all summer
long 57 of all told tell the farmers how fabulous
I effect Texaco motor oil will save money with
their tractors and equipment and their cars too
technical magazines shop there's text coeds and
forty five separate technical magazines that's
published for the 12 biggest different fields of
Industry well I guess you've seen enough magazine
advertising to convince you that they're gonna
have a real program this year but I do want you
to see some of the posters we're gonna have to
I don't know what you fellas think about posters
but I think it's one of the strongest kinds of
advertising that we can have because folks see
poster advertising right when they're on the
road thinking of their cars and thinking of
the kind of gas and oil that they use now I want
to ask your plain fact is there anybody gonna see
this poster it won't make them wanna try this
gasoline which makes drive-in seem like frying
then here's the poster on registered restaurant
with our little gal back again to remind folks
that the Texaco deal is the only place to stop for
these fine clean restaurants and here's the poster
that's being considered for five teen clean as
a whistle human peeling and right to the point